For us artists and rappers, well,
that's a chain, it's a watch or a
piece of clothing, it understands what I mean, look,
get out of the bottom, I made it, I'm here, I'm
brilliant,
tell me logic and greetings
ander rocks
[Music]
I'm from Bayamón, Puerto Rico, as I said
I feel grateful to have been born in
my country since it is a beautiful island and the
neighborhood where I come from also if I have
to be born again I would choose that place I
really like this jeweler for example that
he made me the first watch this is in
my town in  bayamón and it has been there for many years they
are very good jewelry my first
garment because this watch is a marín suit it
was the first watch I bought since
before singing cheap watch no it does not
exceed 400 dollars later I sent it to
customize a diamond it comes out like a thousand
and a few more dollars and I still keep
this others very special this one
a friend who owns a dealer gave me he knows I
like vehicles and a mari suit
too but it is a young edition that
I love  n the tires the h1 and that and the
watch was completely black and I had it
customized as well and I have it I like it
because it is like a rubber like a car tire
one of my favorites the lime skin I think
it is something that is classic I like them
a lot of it is yellow gold up on the face
and all of us is white and has been
fully assembled I like it because you can see that
style as I have put around
thirty-odd thousand dollars I liked that a
lot personally I like
the watch in diamonds  I think it attracts a
lot of attention
I have watches without diamonds such that they are
a collectible watch but I don't
wear them, that is, I have it as an
investment saved this other one is a
speech
this one also likes it and I put
the face on it more  big with diamonds I
like it because they have a combination
of pink and white gold this
cost about 55 thousand dollars
the first one the cheapest
is the same every day the more I like
to wear more comfortable and the more I
love it  You can lose everything the other
months
[Music]
my first career was a yellow gold Cuban
similar to the franco one that was a
little more love or praise it was the
first chain I had my first
gold chain it cost me 5,000 dollars
flight is that I  I am one of
those people who do not like to stay
with the same thing sometimes and what I did every
time something newer came out because I was
changing it, it put a little more 20 changes
and that was what I was doing, I was
changing something for something bigger  You better
understand me and I kept going until I
liked some bigger piece of clothing until, well,
they already won solid gold, I already
had a rib, I understand the
most that I use, it is this one that is the logo of my
company,
the world I really like to wear this
this paradise danny in a jeweler who is
in my very hard friends is the one who takes
care of my clothes also sometimes
this was made for me by italy daimon who is a
jeweler of the alpha and they heard wine also in
my photo it is of my grandmother as with me
When children have many values, they
interview, they understand, I remind them,
it is always there, many people
criticize why
some people buy clothes or
because artists wear clothes, but
many times they do not understand that it is part of
the culture, they understand me, that is, mostly
I have clothes, but not  they all have
some kind of more than the economic value
but rather sentimental because each one
has a meaning when the garments and it
is cultural at least in Puerto
Rico since the salsa of the times the
salsa the salseros always went around with
all their clothes you understand me  you
don't understand something already from culture
comes blood and for us it's like it's
like a trophy it's like a sign of
saying we're having success you
understand me I really like glasses
the collections of a fever that ran
from little boy and with me  brother another
another artist whose name is es I have
one of the first ones from my neighborhood who helped me
with music he also likes
a lot of glasses and well, we spend a lot of time
collecting and that about glasses and I have
glasses I have like khedira that I have almost
as always I like it a lot and I have
different frames that I have on the skin in
diamonds of different colors and
sas and they are also the most that I like
I like and I really like the lime leather, the bags
and everything that is retro so I
say if this is a mount that he
too but this one has diamonds here
in the front part I have these
others that are a little more like they
have a baguette  and they have other bumps
on the lens there are some that I have
bought in diamonds and others that
have been customized and I also
like to change the lens a lot that length
of different colors he combined it with the
clothes with which he likes to customize a
lot  what is the lenses in glasses a
lot also I think that it reaches
even in glasses that in any other
thing I like glasses a lot in my
vice
I have several rings but I try not to
I don't like you  arlo understands me a lot I
always go with one I always have one
because of the combination it depends on the
color I wear I have four rings and this
other one could be simpler a
small stone in the middle I like it a lot in
clothes in jewelry
okay I've already gone a few lengths  out
there there is no good university the
number because the four good ones have left
first of all sing that you
buy as a pledge car whatever
invest in your house you understand me
express your secure your land your
little house the cement that is more important
than everything  this is going to come however you want I
understand and after that if you are going to
buy a garment well you have to be very
careful you understand me because it goes up and down
you understand me to know when to buy the weight
also of what you are going to buy the
carats be all those  little things are very
important not to buy on impulse
because you like the first thing you see and not get
oriented and ask me understand me
before buying any garment grace
atmosphere and clu  b but that they have known
a little more about what my clothes are and
what I like to
wear see you soon and Russian farro at 167
the commissions